[Musik]
schön dass sie wieder bei uns sind und
ein herzliches grüß gott zum militär des
jahres wir zeichnen ja insgesamt in vier
kategorien die angehörigen des
österreichischen bundesheeres für
besondere leistungen aus nun kommen wir
zur sonderkategorie der miliz die
laudatio hält niemand geringerer als der
miliz beauftragter des österreichischen
bundesheeres generalmajor magister erwin
hameseder
meine sehr verehrten damen und herren
die miliz ist ein unverzichtbarer
bestandteil des österreichischen
bundesheer ist dies wurde uns 2020
änderungs voll vor augen geführt als es
im zuge der cobit pandemie zur ersten
teil mobilmachung seit dem zweiten
weltkrieg gekommen ist bürgerinnen und
bürger tauschten ihre zivile
arbeitsbekleidung gegen die soldaten
uniform um die behörden bei der
bekämpfung des corona virus zu
unterstützen
im assistenzeinsatz migration im inland
werde aktuell circa 30 prozent durch die
miliz gestellt um unsere grenzen zu
schützen
ab 20 21 soll die masse der
assistenzsoldaten im einsatz durch die
miliz gestellt werden
dazu gibt es umfassende vorbereitungen
die miliz hilft nicht nur im inland auch
im ausland stellt die miliz circa 50
prozent der einsatz soldaten ohne den
einsatz der miliz bei unseren
kontingenten im libanon in bosnien her
zu gewinnen und im kosovo wäre eine
auftrags erfüllung in der derzeitigen
stärke nicht möglich die angehörigen der
miliz tragen als bürger in uniform durch
militärisches engagement somit
wesentlich zur verankerung der
streitkräfte in der gesellschaft als
miliz beauftragter des österreichischen
bundesheeres freut es mich daher ganz
besonders dass zwei verdient angehörige
der miliz heute einen special award
erhalten
es sind dies frau hauptmann dr anna
käser und herr oberstabsarzt meister
harald biedermann ich gratuliere sehr
herzlich zu dieser ehrenvollen
auszeichnung
ein sonder wort für einen besonderen
status herzlichen glückwunsch und ich
dafür diesen schwierigen zeiten
angepasst den award übergeben
indem ich sie bitten sich vom protest zu
nehmen die anerkennung da kann man daran
ist etwas was mich sehr freut
die ansprache von bataillonskommandant
freut mich natürlich ebenso und ich
finde eigentlich dass jeder
militäreinsatz gewesen des bzw
entsprechend engagiert einen preis
gewinnen sollte harald wiedmann heißt
der bescheidene soldat er ist opa starb
marktmeister und kommandant des
aufklärungs zuges beim jägerbataillon
niederösterreich den sonder award erhält
der miliz soldat einerseits für sein
engagement bei den verschiedenen
informations offensive aber auch für
seine leistung während des einsatzes von
märz bis ende juli 2020
wir wollen in den ersten sechs wochen an
der grenze zu tschechien in den bezirken
horn und hollabrunn
danach sind ins bund land verlegt und
haben dort gemeinsam mit der gerade die
grenzübergänge in nickelsdorf und kitze
zu überwachen gehabt und man muss sich
mal vorstellen was das den aufwand für
einen milizsoldaten ist jetzt aus dem
privatleben gerissen wird und dann dort
hier diese tätigkeiten durchführen darf
wir hatten einen tag bis zu 16.000
kontrollen um den spitzenzeiten bis zu
60.000 kontroll und das an die leute
hatten entsprechend geworden doch bei
den vier monaten einsatz sollte es
dieses jahr nicht bleiben der überzeugte
miliz soldat hat auch diese woche für
eine miliz übung wieder seine
zivilkleidung gegen die uniform
getauscht es ist für eine milizsoldaten
glaube ganz abwechslungsreich
mal abgesehen von seinem zivilberuf
hierher zu kommen mit ganz anderen
personen zu tun zu haben also
normalerweise mit ganz anderen aufgaben
mit ganz anderen tätigkeiten behaftet zu
werden und diese auch entsprechend zu
erfüllen und der vorteil als mit soldat
ist natürlich dass man auch die privaten
erfahrungen hier mit einbringen kann die
private kontakte mit einbringen kann und
sozusagen ein breit für das umfeld an
wissen wir ins milizsystem mit
einbringen
mich macht das stolz mit soll da zu sein
ich bin ein patriot ich mag dieses land
ich liebe dieses land österreich ist ein
tolles land wir können stolz darauf sein
dass wir hier wohnen dürfen dass es uns
so gut geht dass wir uns so sicher
fühlen dürfen
und das ist mein beitrag zu dem was mit
diesen anderen bericht auch hauptmann
anna kaiser ist vom konzept des bürgers
in uniform überzeugt für ihr besonderes
engagement beim bundesheer wird auch sie
mit einem sonder award ausgezeichnet ist
natürlich eine große ehre diese
auszeichnung entgegen nehmen zu dürfen
ich möchte an dieser stelle versorgen
dass ich diese auszeichnung den
soldatinnen und soldaten widmen möchte
die mit meiner kompanie in den einzeln
gegangen sind im mai und im juni nämlich
den soldaten der kompanie tui um auf die
ich unglaublich stolz bin
neben ihren aufgaben als kommandantin
der mediziner kompanie schulen engagiert
sich die stolze milizsoldaten auch in
der öffentlichkeitsarbeit wie zb bei
einer werbekampagne zum internationalen
frauentag
da waren natürlich auch wichtig denn
damen da draußen zu zeigen dass es auch
in der miliz für frauen die möglichkeit
gibt und dass es eine miliz auch frauen
gibt die verantwortung übernehmen und
die persönlich würden natürlich freuen
wenn es mehrere frauen beim heer oder
weiterfahren hergibt und besonders auch
in der miliz das dass frau sein wenn er
zu einer selbstverständlichkeit wird
nicht selbstverständlich ist für
hauptmann kaiser die im zivilen leben an
der donau universität krems als
lehrgangs und projektleiterin tätig ist
das besondere engagement ihrer kameraden
soldaten besteht die freiwillig ihre
freizeit aufbringen um sich militärisch
weiterzubilden fortzubilden ihre
kenntnisse zu erhalten und das ist eine
motivation so entsprechend auch meine
soldaten dazu geben wofür sie ihre
freizeit opfern
das ist eine riesenmotivation auch von
uns einen herzlichen glückwunsch an die
ausgezeichneten der sonderkategorie
miliz in der nächsten folge lernen sie
die einheit des jahres kennen
machen sie es gut und bleiben sie gesund
[Musik]